oh yeah nice iPad Pro oh yeah yeah this
is the new one too oh neat I I heard
about that what is that what does anyone
do
well you know
um
it's got that it
it's
more of the same uh
[Music]
hey what's up HD here and this is the
new new iPad Pro
um you couldn't really tell from the
outside because it is exactly the same
as the one we got with the M1 chip a
year and a half ago it is the same
excellent display the sweet promotion
mini LED on the 12.9 inch version and
led on the 11 inch it's the same usb-c
port with Thunderbolt the same battery
same stereo speakers same webcam
placement same second gen apple pencil
support literally from the outside you
cannot tell it is a new one unless you
know that this little bit of text on
here that says iPad Pro at the bottom it
used to just say iPad before so that's
new okay okay I got it I got it this one
it has the new M2 Chip inside instead of
the M1
oh tight so like I can do more stuff
right
well no it does the same stuff but
faster again it's the same iPad but it
has an M2 Chip inside now instead of the
old M1 from a year and a half ago which
to a logical person would imply that
this one is capable of something that
the old M1 version wasn't capable of
and
technically yes so the M1 chip was
already ludicrously over the top fast
for an iPad very powerful the M2 is
another bump up to that so in raw
performance you're looking at 10 to 15
faster CPU and 30 to 40 faster Graphics
all with the same battery life it's just
silly at this point uh it's it's also
still running iPad OS 16 that every
previous iPad is also running but this
iPad has more raw horsepower than a lot
of mid-range and higher end laptops even
more than Apple's own M1 iMac so yeah if
there was some theoretical application
that you were running on your iPad and
the M1 just wasn't up to the task it
just wasn't powerful enough to handle it
then this M2 iPad May finally be able to
handle that just kidding that's probably
not a real scenario but this will
shorten the time of some exports of your
absolute largest video or 3D projects
you're doing on the iPad oh you know
what else this version has Wi-Fi 6E
60 what six e so it so so this one's
it's going to be a little more future
proof a little faster which is kind of
cool I guess I don't know you know what
else though
what prores video this one can shoot
it's capable of shooting Perez video
that I think I heard about that sounds
pretty cool can I see so uh so I'd have
to download another app to show you
which I don't have right now
um
but it is capable of it yeah you might
have seen on Apple's site and in their
marketing materials that prores video
capture is one of the new features but
it's actually not in the stock camera
app like if you were just getting this
iPad just to make it your mobile video
Studio like in the commercials first of
all I don't know if we could be friends
but hey if that's you you do you you get
this iPad you take it out the box you
fire it up and you open up the camera
settings like I did you won't find
prores in there because it's not
supported by Apple's own iPad camera app
so you require a third-party app like
filmic Pro for that video Studio oh
probably the biggest new feature is the
pencil hover uh right mine does not do
that exactly so that's exclusive to the
M2
for some reason
but yeah
it's the new one so basically when you
get the apple pencil close to the iPad
screen within 12 millimeters it'll show
you a preview of what you're about to do
so similar to some other professional
Wacom tablets you basically get a little
preview of what's about to happen when
you put the pen to the screen and then
you actually do it so if you're about to
hit an icon or a widget on the home
screen it'll show that and if you're
about to paint or write something it can
show that and then even if you're doing
some watercolor brushes in the notes app
not only does it show where the brush
stroke will be but it shows you a mix of
what two colors would look like if you
painted on top of each other but then
you can also adjust the size of the
brush stroke with a pinch with one hand
while you move the pen around with the
other it's pretty sick actually so this
works across iPad OS and all Apple's
apps and then even some third-party apps
now are also starting to take advantage
of this hover thing So pixelmator Pro
for example will show previews of
Applied effects and filters on a hover
so it's great now again I don't know if
this would have been impossible to do
with the M1 chip but they didn't so yeah
that's the difference but then that's it
it's their best iPad ever by the small
amount of the new chip prores video
Wi-Fi 60 and hover which you know got me
thinking all the existential questions
again of like what is this product even
why is this iPad so ridiculously
powerful what what is an iPad Pro like
in 99 of use cases regular people will
never be able to tell the difference
between an M1 iPad Pro and an M2 iPad
Pro
that doesn't mean they shouldn't have
made it it's still better but that's
cool but maybe maybe in those last one
percent the real pros will be able to
notice and feel the difference and they
should definitely get this one over the
refurbished M1 iPad Pro but who what is
that one percent who what is an iPad Pro
user what is a pro iPad user and really
that just zooms me out to their bigger
question what does pro mean in Apple's
lineups because they use that word a lot
I went through every single product that
Apple sells right now that has the word
Pro in the name and it turns out there's
really two definitions two buckets of
what Pro is one is what you would think
Pro is which is professional which is
people who actually make money from
using a certain product and that money
helps them pay for it it's just a
professional relationship you're a pro
user of that product and the other is an
enthusiastic user who likes the high-end
version so this is how I divide it up in
their current lineup now also these
aren't super rigid lines I think you
could make some arguments You could
argue that some people take enough phone
calls on their airpods Pro that they are
pro airpods users and there's plenty of
MacBook Pro users also who just had
money to burn and wanted the one with
the nicer screen they just got the more
expensive one and there's definitely a
professional colorist already down in
the comments typing away that the pro
display xdr isn't a real editing display
so you know we can we can bend these
lines for sure but the iPad to me still
feels like the the blurriest mix of them
all maybe it's just because I know a lot
of these people but there's clearly a
lot of enthusiastic users but there are
also lots of professionals making the
iPad Pro work for their workflow maybe
they're bending it around the iPad a
little bit but there's lots of people
using pixelmator and procreate and The
DaVinci Resolve app is coming to the
iPad soon so that's real hardcore
excellent apps that people are making
money with and using for their work but
then at the same time like our graphic
designer Tim here would probably
probably laugh at the idea of using an
iPad instead of the Wacom tablet and
also I'm a video editor and as powerful
as this iPad is I can't use Final Cut
Pro on the iPad Pro still so I guess all
this is to say it doesn't really mean
anything don't put yourself into a
bucket the word Pro really is is clearly
just used to sell you on something and
to make you feel like you're getting the
best thing and professionals like nice
things so I would like the pro thing too
and of course some other companies still
use different words uh Samsung and
xiaomi love Ultra for example some
others still use the word plus but my
bottom line on this new iPad Pro with M2
is if you're someone going iPad shopping
yes this is now the best iPad you can
get and it's phenomenal it's really
really good but also if you think about
how exactly you're going to be using
this iPad and prores video Never crosses
your mind drawing with the pencil isn't
on your list you can basically have this
exact same experience for 300 off
already at this point by getting an M1
I'd like to think that we're in for
possibly a bigger iPad Pro update soon
in the future things like adding the
webcam to the long side instead of the
short side where it stayed for so many
years or you know more meaningful things
like a display Improvement battery
improvements speaker improvements camera
updates to the latest sensors things
like that they could all happen but
until then I'm going to keep using my
nearly three-year-old a12z iPad Pro that
does all the same stuff that I want out
of an iPad Pro but without the newest
chip don't let this distract you from
the fact that the iPad is still an
incredible tablet by far one of my
favorite tablets ever made but if the
iPad Pro's potential could please
present itself that'd be great
until then the Paradox of iPad Pro
prevails
thanks for watching
catch you the next one
[Music]